[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler and today we are
talking about apologies good and bad
ones so you know we're sorry if you
don't like the topic but that's what
we're going to talk about for roughly
the next hour and it turns out that
apologies are a good bit more
complicated than
many people think i mean if you've ever
made a bad apology and then tried to
recover yourself after doing so you find
out just how complicated they can be
and how complicated dealing with other
people who are not happy with your
apology can be right but yeah we're
going to explore the ins and outs we've
got some
cool scenarios some drawn from the
headlines ripped from real life to
examine but we're hopefully going to
give some
some ideas about how to apologize well
and now dan this is a topic that you
originally pitched why did you want to
go into apologies
i think they're
a
a very large component of you know
maintaining
relationships it's definitely an uh
an expression of ethics um and we can
we'll get into a little bit of like the
different reasons why different uh
ethical systems will
choose to apologize um but also just uh
you know it's
in the culture it's it's part of the
zeitgeist of you know you see uh the
the youtuber that that has somehow
transgressed and then they they have
some crying overly dramatic you know a
big balling uh apology but even though
they they look like they're a you know a
wreck they they still
just whiff on these apologies
you know the constant um i'm sorry that
you feel that yeah that's a good one
i'm
just uh or just apologizing in order to
try to you know um
sue the crowd even though you don't
actually believe it and it's usually
really apparent
uh that
they do that i guess you could
potentially if you're a good enough
actor you'll mimic what a good apology
is but that only is uh good enough for
the speech act of the apology but
there's you know much more there's
actual restitution and there's changing
of you know um actions that are going to
then proceed after that and those things
you know you can't just get away with an
act that's a really interesting point
that i want to come back to and maybe
we'll hit on this more there seem to be
a lot of people who are very very
clueless
about how apologies work and
why they matter and why they should do
them right
and it strikes me as kind of similar to
students who plagiarize you know the
majority of plagiarism that we see out
there it's it's so badly done that it's
super easy to catch and it's funny
because
they there was a conversation on this a
long conversation between professors on
twitter because there's a new
tool that's being used by students to
paraphrase and of course they're totally
screwing it up you know it's a it's an
ai like paraphraser kind of generator
and instead of working well it creates
goofy paraphrases that a professor
reading the thing can easily catch and
and somebody remarked
why is it that students who plagiarize
think that we professors are
so dumb that we're not going to catch
these like really easy ones and it's i
think it's the same way with a lot of
bad apologies you know the people who
are giving them
you look at them and you're almost like
shocked you're like how can you possibly
think that would make things better
right
yeah it's
it's
surprising and it i don't know if it's
just like
one is not taught how to actually do
this properly we obviously teach our
kids to like you know say i'm sorry
but like that's
uh as we'll go into just saying i'm
sorry is not an apology yeah um
and
i don't know it's it's it's a little bit
baffling that uh people can
go through life and and get to their you
know maybe your 20s or something and
don't have
um
a moment in when they had to apologize
uh
well you know that's i mean maybe some
people never apologize sincerely if
they're very egotistical or manipulative
and i think you're right most people
actually don't get much teaching or even
coaching on how to how to apologize well
it's usually it's sort of like anger
management you know
in our society we have lots and lots of
angry people we don't really teach anger
management in like you know middle
school or high school curriculum where
it might actually be very helpful
and generally you have to like cross a
threshold you have to screw up enough
and then they send you an anger
management class and now you start
getting resources and learning about it
but you have to like really have screwed
up
to
merit that and maybe it's that way with
apologies
except that i think a lot of people
never get any coaching no matter how bad
they are with the apologies or if they
do it's just they happen to have a
mentor who pays attention to them or
somebody else in their life who says hey
man you're screwing up fix this
yeah yes you'd hope that
the parents
would be the the first line of defense
for you know
kind of nipping this in the bud too yeah
but through teaching like but you know
you never know and you can't make an
assumption about what
the parents were taught or what skills
that they have so um but i guess why is
it important for us to apologize in the
first place yeah
well you know as social and rational
animals this is something we've talked
about a lot on this show we're not just
pure individuals we exist in in
relationships
we're going to screw up quite a bit and
then we have to figure out how to fix
the relationship or or how to at least
get things back on
track and there's lots and lots and lots
of things that we can do to make things
bad we can insult people
we can injure them in some way we can do
damage to their stuff we can negatively
affect them without even you know
meaning to
um like you know cutting somebody off in
traffic even though we didn't even
realize that they were there
we can do wrong to people we we often do
offend people
i mean if you're actually saying and
doing the right things you almost
automatically will offend somebody
you know we can misrepresent them nobody
likes um
being told that they're this way when
they're really a different way and and
we can we can cut people to the heart by
betraying them we disappoint people
those are just a few of the
many things that we might need to
apologize for right
right
this kind of brings to mind like
maybe uh to answer the question earlier
as a a hypothesis the reason why
we're not maybe as good
of apologizers is that we don't
communities anymore and that we can get
away with
kind of being the a-hole
yeah
because you you don't have to maintain
those relationships at one point in time
if you were outside the group you got
ostracized and that was almost
tantamount to death if you're in a you
know a small tribal group
yeah
i mean and now that's not the this
that's there's not that you know
deterrent
you do have some ways in which you might
be in a smaller group like maybe you
live with neighbors but if you know if
you're in a neighborhood that's one
thing if you're an apartment complex
where people are coming and going
frequently maybe you don't know any of
them and we could say school right but i
mean we've been out of school for a long
time for students at least they have to
deal with each other and i guess their
teachers
regularly the workplace you know that's
an interesting one because so much work
has gone online right
we don't have the same contact with
people if we're doing
um
zoom meetings as we do when we're
sitting down
and deciding you know who's gonna get
the last donut or you know who's gonna
go make the coffee
those sort of workplace things right
right
um
but we also have uh
these
what it is to actually set up an apology
is to you know uh set things right yeah
um making things right or between people
as well as groups
um
and you know apologies uh when they are
real apologies are ways of acknowledging
and taking responsibility
i think that's really a key aspect of it
i mean as you used the word speech act
earlier and we should talk a little bit
about that for any
listeners who don't know what we're
referencing this is an idea that's been
around for a very long time but was
formulated by
a philosopher whose his name was austin
and he noticed that you know whenever
we're talking were doing something with
words
and
apologizing was one of the kind of
speech acts that he called performative
i mean and it's not performative in the
sense of like putting on a show
or
being fake
although of course we can make fake
apologies
it means that we're doing something
we're performing the very thing
as we announce it so if i say oh dan i'm
sorry i apologize
my saying i apologize that's the apology
in part right
and
you know that's that's an important uh
feature you could say of a lot of our
language
that we're
we're doing things we're not you know
and and so the apology itself this is
something we're going to talk about
later
the apology itself is an action that we
might screw up and then have to
apologize for again
right
right this reminds me of another speech
act of like you know uh publicly reading
one's vows to it during a wedding yeah
yeah this is this is a a public display
of
um you know some either act or on a
commitment that is going to be uh
followed through upon
yeah in saying i the wed if we have this
old formulation that is the actual
wedding right there or at least half of
it right because one person says it then
the other person says it yeah
yeah
um so i guess what is a good apology um
and so we talked a little bit about like
just some topics about apology but like
what is the meat and so here we go um so
like a clear speech act of i'm sorry are
an i apologize statement um and then you
know a a sincere expression of regret
this is one of the things like little
kids don't always get right right yeah
they they often feel they they say well
i'm not gonna apologize because i'm not
sorry right right
or i'm only apologizing because my mom
told me to exactly yeah yeah so um but
actually
sincere expression regret an
acknowledgement of the social norms or
expectations that were broken
an acknowledgement of the responsibility
now what does that you mean
uh the responsibility yeah
what does it mean to be responsible in
this this case
so you're you're saying like i i've done
this thing and it was my own actions to
actually take that upon yourself instead
of like kind of otherwising it's like
i'm sorry like the the earlier we're
talking about like i'm sorry that you
felt
something or where is that
mistakes were made
oh yeah
um
and now now we're like removing
ourselves from the act
and and you really need to if we're
doing an honest apology you have to
acknowledge the things that you actually
did and take responsibility for the
actions that you did
um a a declaration of repentance so i
don't want to do that anymore
um
and
um some offer of restitution you know
making it right yeah right and so you
could potentially do this beforehand if
you like you know broke something or got
rid of
um
consume something on on on
you know if someone says something like
candies and hey like you're a roommate
and you happen to eat them
oh shoot this those are those are mobs
exactly
um
uh
it's good to you know probably be a
little proactive there if possible um
and then on
a request for forgiveness um but this is
something that you know as we'll go in
later
um this is not something that you're
required or obliged to get you can ask
for it but this is something that is
totally outside of your control
why do you think the request for
forgiveness is
an integral part of apologies i i mean i
think it is too but
what do you think that's about
um it is
really about the the
trying to set things right again like we
we have this um
transgression that has happened and has
damaged the relationship somehow and
this is what is hopefully the the
outcome of this apology is to try to
mend those relationships um
unless you have anything more that you
feel well i i was thinking about this as
you were talking about it you know
there's a lot of people that don't like
to apologize right and some people just
will not apologize at all or they won't
give good apologies and that request for
forgiveness part is one of the often
left out things people are like
hey i said i'm sorry that's enough right
and
maybe there's there's a feeling
and i think there there probably is on a
lot of people's part that when you have
to ask forgiveness from another person
you're making yourself
vulnerable to them and maybe putting
yourself in for possible humiliation or
having your feelings hurt or something
like that and they just don't want to do
it so they they ignore that and they try
to move on
yeah you're you're you're
i think it's it's really necessary to be
put into a vulnerable position because
you've already done something that was
you
transgressing transgressing at some
point
um and so you you've already kind of
done something that puts you in a place
of power and this is you know you coming
and
um
you know hat in hand and saying like
i've acknowledged this and i really
shouldn't have taken that uh for myself
yeah that's that's that's good so
one of the very first cases that we are
going to look at is a recent one
um right-wing culture warrior and
anti-vaxxer robert f kennedy jr recently
made an apology that a lot of people
called him on and said
that's not a very good apology and what
he did so here's what he actually said
i apologize for my reference to anne
frank especially to families that
suffered the holocaust horrors
my intention was to use examples of past
barbarism to show that the perils from
new technologies of control to the
extent my remarks caused hurt i'm truly
and deeply sorry and so a lot of people
chimed in on this and said
um well this is first of all his typical
ammo to give fake apologies that that
don't really address things
what he was doing was was essentially
what a lot of people are doing right now
trying to use anne frank and and the
nazis by direct comparison to um what's
going on with vaccine mandates and
things like that so a lot of people were
offended and i think rightly so
and one response was to point out
so going back to the the repentance part
right and then doing things differently
so this is the second time in seven
years that we know of that you've done
the exact same thing
and apologized for it how many more
times in the future can we expect you to
say it again and have to apologize so
that's a bad sign you know it would be
different if like he'd
said something you know also offensive
but in it on a different topic and
they're saying oh you know once in seven
years you you apologize for something
this is the same topic so clearly the
last apology
wasn't sincere why should we think it's
sort of like the boy who cried wolf
thing isn't it
right right so that's that's an
interesting one another person said an
apology acknowledges wrongdoing
not just offense
so this goes directly to one of the
things he didn't take responsibility
right no
yeah
and then yeah the third i'm just looking
at the quote again and yeah and
dissecting again it's just it's not
there yeah the third thing somebody said
apologies don't have qualifiers
i'm curious to know what you think about
this more generally but so in this case
qualifiers like to the extent my remarks
caused hurt
nor statements attempting to clarify the
intent of your wrong this is not an
apology it's pr they they said
now
so there's two things going on there and
to the extent that my remarks caused
hurt yeah i think that qualifier
turns
everything that follows after that you
know saying i'm truly and deeply sorry
you can't be truly deeply sorry if
you're only sorry to the extent that
your your remarks caused hurt right
like people told you that they caused
hurt you say i cause
some hurt and damage
by doing this thing i am taking
responsibility for my actions
when you would throw those qualifiers in
it just
it sours the whole thing yeah that's
actually a good point if somebody has
already told you do you really have
do you really have any grounds i don't
want to say do you have the right
because anybody can say anything do you
have any good grounds for making a
qualification like to the extent when
you already know that it is to this
extent
you know
or you're like well i'm apologizing for
this thing but some other people said
that um they hurt me in other ways so
i'm not talking about those
so you're now you're excluding you know
not that that
might be
true in this case but like we're we're
parsing the sentence yeah
the other thing you know
so i'm kind of divided on on this issue
in general but i think it was a mistake
in the case of robert kennedy jr
to do this
if you're apologizing to somebody should
you tell them why you did the thing that
you did or why you said the thing that
you did in this case
or is putting your own motives and
intentions in it
you know watering down
the
i'm sorry effect of the apology i mean
there's that old thing to understand is
to excuse and maybe a lot of people want
to be understood and thereby excused
when they say well yeah my motives were
doing this
in this case i think he was off base to
do that but you know there i think we
could imagine cases where somebody says
oh you know i didn't mean to ding your
car
i was actually like opening up a pack of
uh i was opening up a stick of chewing
gum and looking down at that as i was
driving in the crowded street and i
accidentally you know nudged your car
because of that um that might not
necessarily be a bad apology because of
that
i think
i think that's still weakens the apology
if you're like oh i accidentally did
this because i was doing this other
thing that was wrong
you know like
in the example that you just gave
um
is you know i i was being an inattentive
driver and eating while driving and
at that point in time you say i was
wrong to do that that should be part of
your apology and okay i need to not do
that while i'm driving because it
resulted in this consequence of this
even though you weren't like intending
to do that most of us don't intend to
uh harm people but we still do it so so
to take a similarly structured thing
like let's say you and i get into an
argument i lose control of my temper and
i call you some some terrible name right
um
actually like you know you told me about
the thing that they used to call you
back in middle school because everybody
had some some middle school name that
they got and i i deliberately use that
on you right
and then you're mad at me afterwards and
i come and i say oh dan i'm so sorry
i was mad at you and that's why i said
that thing if i if i say i was mad at
you and i'm using that to sort of
justify what i'm doing clearly not an
apology if i'm just kind of throwing it
in maybe it's not helpful if i say i was
mad at you and i shouldn't have gotten
mad at you that's the second bad thing
that i did and that led to this other
bad thing
then that could make for a better
apology right
yes i would absolutely agree
okay well let's talk about different
kinds of apologies one of the
papers that i use when i'm teaching
business ethics
is
called why saying i'm sorry is not good
enough the ethics of corporate apologies
and it's by this guy darryl kern in
business ethics quarterly and he makes a
distinction between three different
kinds of apologies and i think it can be
helpful for us to bring this in
we're mostly focusing on one but we
could be focused on others so he breaks
it down into private or interpersonal
apologies like the ones that we've been
discussing
so far and then corporate or ceo
apologies and that's what his paper
focuses on and i think it's actually a
really good examination about how
corporate apologies often
don't
meet the mark they don't they don't
achieve what they're supposed to do
and then he talks about nation state or
collective apologies like you know if we
if we apologize for slavery you know
to african americans as a nation
and acknowledge the wrong and the harm
that was done and apologize for not
following through on reconstruction and
go on and on and on right those those
are those kinds of apologies
and each of these has its own
characteristics you know you don't
necessarily expect the same thing
out of an interpersonal apology as you
do out from a corporate ceo
i don't think this covers all the
grounds though you know we we talked
about kids
and making them apologize i i think we
could call those training apologies and
we don't we don't expect them to be
totally
genuine sincere effective
we're just trying to like get people
into the groove of
recognizing that you know norms have
been broken other people have seen it
they got to do something
and you know we can screw kids up we can
like say well all you got to do is say
you're sorry and then you move on
and that's not a good way to do it but i
think those training apologies could be
quite good and maybe we extend those to
adults that are not all that morally
developed you know if we're if we're
training them or coaching them
right you know what's the
like you you don't come out of the womb
with a fully developed like empathetic
response no to the other people around
you in the world so yeah a lot of times
you know like little kids
they're selfish
because they they haven't quite fully
developed that that fully human aspect
of us being social creatures yeah that
takes time
um and before that like it's like as you
said like the training i think is very
useful another one that i've seen is on
oh uh yo you hit timmy over there make
the face that you think timmy would
make
that that happened to him kind of like
as a training
yeah because they might not get it as
concepts of being sad yeah yeah they
really get like oh i got hurt and this
is the face that i usually make
yeah
and the ability to do that that's
something very important for uh for
human beings right to be able to
recognize other people's emotions we
call that emotional intelligence
um
you know there's other apologies that
get made by
people
who aren't ceos in virtue of their role
or their function like a teacher could
apologize for
not having as i've done sometimes in the
past not having everything ready for the
students you know not having everything
in the course management system
um you know doctors nurses could
apologize for
causing pain to a patient when they
didn't mean to
police could apologize for uh you know
treating people unjustly um
and then i i'm curious to see what you
think about this
apologies that are private and
interpersonal but we make publicly
do those become different by being put
out there like on the internet you know
in social media
they're they're
they're there for the person right it's
an interpersonal thing
but it's also
there for
the public
who get to to see it does does what do
you think about that does that i mean
actually one of the cases that you have
with dan harmon a very public apology
right incredibly yeah yeah is that is
that different than an interpersonal
where it's more private apology
i mean it can certainly have different
effects right i mean right that's
actually like when you asked me early on
why
um
do i want to talk about this this dan
harmon apology is one of the things that
like really wanted made me kind of dig
into this subject
and and because of how
like
you know
extended and in depth and
how it hits all the marks really well
yeah um is a really good case study of
how to do this properly and especially
in something that you almost never see
from you know your uh
people in in power and corporate because
there's always this your cya right um
going on and and this was very much like
you put it all out there in in a very uh
like honest and
you know vulnerable way yeah and
um like
i guess i would hope that more are kind
of like the
um the private because i don't i think
that we
it is useful for us to have exemplars
that we can easily point to of how we
should be acting once we transgress
against others well let's talk about
this case study can you lead us through
what actually happened
um because i think this is this is one
that you know
we probably should publicize more
because the fan base of say you know
rick and morty um could probably use
some
lessons in how to apologize given some
of the craziness that you know as a fan
base they've engaged in
so um
during the
uh
while they're writing communities so
another show that dan harmon created
before this which is absolutely amazing
in my opinion is community
um and um you know as there is for any
tv show especially comedies there's a
writer's room and there are people that
are were on working within it and um one
of the
uh the new writers uh to the show is a
um
a young woman who was one of her first
on jobs in the industry and
um
harmon had uh got out of a
um
don't i don't know exactly i thought
this was like after his wife he left his
wife but i'm not quite sure of the
timeline there but regardless um he is
uh there in a position of power and um
he becomes enamored with this writer and
um you know is
shoveling praise on to this woman and is
on
you know taking her
um her
ideas and running with them and um
uh
you know kind of
being absolutely infatuated and and like
falling in love with this woman but in a
kind of a place where this is
really hard for you know as you see um
over and over again um when you have a a
person in a position of power and that
being romantically interested in another
it becomes really difficult for one to
you know
rebuff those advances without actually
uh like
losing their job or potentially having
some sort of um
vengeance taken upon them yeah yeah
and
um he
um
she
eventually
or he eventually like confesses
his love for her and she's not
interested in him and says rejects him
but this but that was like okay well can
i even stay here on this writing room
yeah it makes things pretty awkward
right um yeah and not only is it
this
like
big awkwardness and this power
differential but it made her feel as
though
um
everything that she wrote was now
suspects no longer was it on her own
merit as a writer but
uh because she was the
the
locus of infatuation
for mr harmon and so
um here we have a dan harmon set on
harmontown
where he he does this public apology
afterwards that he realizes that his
aggressive behavior could undercut her
faith in her talent and lo it did he
acknowledged that by singling her out
and centering their professional
interactions with one another on his
attraction to her he made her question
her own skills not to mention her
ability to understand the harassment
from where it was
and what it was
i destroyed everything harmon said i
damaged her internal compass
yeah so this shows a lot of awareness on
his part right and it's interesting too
because if you
think about this particular case being
attracted to somebody not a bad thing in
and of itself right and
attraction law of these things we
usually view as good and we usually
think oh somebody's somebody loves
somebody else
and they're helping them out that's a
good thing but in this case
it turns out to be a bad thing precisely
because now she's thrown into what's
essentially an epistemological quandary
she does not know
whether she's succeeding on her own
talent and hard work or whether this
other thing is going on and so something
that could be good
winds up uh having the opposite effect
right
right
and so um goes on to say
this is a basic
and familiar pattern for men and
position a powerful man sees you a woman
who is young and who thinks she might be
talented a person who conveniently
exists in a female body and he
understands that he can tie your
potential to your female body and
threaten the latter then you will never
be quite as sure of the former again
yeah
and so
what happens after this is not only does
he um he he says that he um
he once this happened and she leaves
it was kind of out of sight out of mind
and okay says i did
i did it by not thinking about it he
wasn't thinking about the repercussions
of his actions when he was infatuated
with her in the first place and then he
said i damaged her i'm sorry i i got
away with it by not thinking about it as
well and so this is you know just kind
of going through and kind of floating
through
um as as a um a defense mechanism of
actually not actually dealing with this
instead of actually taking
responsibility and um only
um
you know years later um did he like
fully realize this um
because she she made a tweet kind of
like calling him out on this [ __ ]
okay and and usually people get
incredibly defensive that's right yeah
and he he took it as like a wake-up call
and um so there's actually uh
he has the or he had a podcast called
harmontown
and um there's a clip from it you can
find it it's seven minutes long of him
doing an apology and going through all
these tips he takes responsibility in
detail enumerated the things that he did
and then uh specifically details
how those acts impacted
her in the moment and in the future so
we talked about how this was damaging to
her her internal compass of what if her
work was actually good or not yeah that
um do you
i mean it's it's a very interesting case
and
like you said it's it's pretty much a
rarity i mean this came out during the
metoo stuff i think right if yeah so
that was a time when
people are often people who have power
in whatever way are usually defensive
when they get called out on having done
something wrong if it's if it was a long
time in the past maybe even more so i
would imagine
that for
men
being accused of having done something
during the me too like revelations
they would be even more on their guard
first so for him to do that is actually
like you said it's a it's a good example
of somebody really taking responsibility
and
what what came of it was there was there
actually a reproachment or
um
so uh
she
she was very like
one stunned
that this happened
that he apologized you mean
yeah in a fully truthful way
um
and
i'm
and and it i guess
like we were talking about like public
versus private um like this was
um
definitely something that was done in a
public forum partly because maybe she
he thought it was
the correct place when we do
a a public um
not uh sorry uh she because she made it
uh
on on twitter and she's not working with
him anymore so there's no direct contact
anymore um
it's definitely
like
kind of tit for tat for like the
platform in which this is happening yeah
yeah um that makes sense
i mean yeah there's there's a quote in
here um
by her talking about how she's like i'm
not dreaming this actually happens i
have like the podcast i can re-rewind it
yeah i mean is it a better apology by
being made public
do you think or
okay
i just happen to think that it it
happens to be in the public sphere
the only thing that's the benefit of it
being of the public spheres it's a good
example that people can point to
you know one of the things we were going
to talk about and we might not go into
it as much is sort of the ethics of why
why one should apologize and
you know in terms of virtue ethics
having examples like this is very
important
but i'm wondering if from a utilitarian
perspective where we're trying to
maximize benefit minimize harm
maybe public apologies are really the
way to go because
if they're done right like like dan
harmon's is they
can you know they can show you how it's
supposed to be done it can lead to other
people doing the right thing
i i don't know i think maybe from a
utilitarian perspective a public apology
like this is better but conversely
bad public apologies would be
significantly worse
than bad private apologies
yeah
so let's talk so let's oh he's going to
say let's talk about bad apologies what
what makes apologies
bad and before we get to that there's a
preliminary thing where people
definitely don't take responsibility and
this is something we could actually do
like an entire show on
um there should be a name for this this
this sort of shtick that gets done
denying the need for an apology so you
say to somebody hey you did x and they
say no no i didn't do x obviously they
don't need to apologize for that and
then after a while they're like well
actually i did do x but i didn't intend
to do it so i can't apologize for what i
didn't really mean to do
and then they'll say well actually i did
do x and i did intend to do it but it's
really not so bad so i don't need to
apologize to you for that
and then they'll say well i did do it
and
you know i intended to do it and it was
bad but i had to do it i was forced to
do it by whatever circumstances so it's
not really my fault and interestingly
this is an old pattern aristotle
identifies this in a book called the
rhetoric people will do this in law
courts so they do this all the time in
real life too
and if you do that there's no way you
can apologize because you're not taking
any responsibility for what you're doing
right
right
what are some other ways people
well let's talk about how people do
apologize and then mess it up
right so um
i guess
the
do you want to do the i didn't do x
thing or do you want to go to the let's
talk about apologizing for the wrong
thing
okay people will make apologies
and i mean in a certain way i'm sorry i
offended you
is a subclass of this right because i'm
sorry i offended you because i said
something
horrible or did something awful now that
wouldn't be a problematic apology in
that respect but i'm sorry you took
offense that places it on the other
person
and you know you can apologize for only
a quarter of what you did you can
apologize for the things that are easy
for um
you to express right some aspect that
the the other person's not really that
upset about you don't get to the core
issue
or you can tell them all about why you
did it you know your your motives uh
focusing on that rather than the effects
of the action or why the action is wrong
and these are misdirection i think
they're not necessarily deliberate
misdirection strategies but they're a
sign of somebody trying to
change the topic in a way in the middle
of the apology
yeah they
either
they don't believe that they should
apologize but they feel like they
they're required to make some apology
um or
yeah
that they're i think it's a common one
yeah yeah
um or
they just
yeah i guess that what i was going to
say next you know still fits into that
previous category okay
oh uh you know oh you were you were
upset you know this is kind of like the
uh
oh what's the that stupid line um
uh facts don't care about your feelings
or something along those lines right
yeah yeah
yeah i'm sorry you're such a snowflake
you know that's not an apology at all
that's that's reinsulting the person you
know yeah
um
so we can also have another example of
poor apologies is apologizing with tones
you know and gestures and words that uh
show that they're all apologetic so
we've all seen that like i'm sorry sorry
sarcastically
you know i'm saying that you know once
again talking about like that um you
know i'm sorry is it your snowflake um
and and doing um oh uh was it uh to
quote way or on you two um uh yeah
constantly oh like
well they do it too or you're you'll see
this in politics all the time like yo oh
the
if it's something on the the left oh the
right does it as well or you know or
vice versa or the left does it as well
yeah and it doesn't actually
uh apologize for anything
um it's just
another variation of that is
i'm really sorry that i did x
now do you have anything that you would
like to apologize for in you know in
relation to that
it feels like it feels manipulative
right
right
um
and if you're gonna do that and you're
in a like actual relationship with this
person that doesn't seem like a way to
like maintain that relationship well
yeah yeah uh you know the if the the
goal here is to actually maintain those
relationships there's a lot of there's
things that you can do that's kind of um
benign and there are things that are
actually actively going to
hurt that relationship and that's
definitely one of them yeah trying to
score points places
one self over the relationship you could
say right mm-hmm
you know i always apologize
i always loved the comment of it
if it's in a relationship it should be
you two against the problem not you
against the other i like that that that
is a good one yeah
um i kind of like that better than all
the variations on it's not just you two
in the relationship there's a third
person involved you see all the memes
for right
and it could be god it could be the
government it could be whoever you gotta
consult somebody else i i like this this
better that it's you two against
doesn't have to be the whole world but
certainly just the problem whatever
you're you're the the challenge the yeah
it's a whole reframing if it's not i
have to get one over on my partner it's
we we are working together to
solve an issue yeah
now another way people go wrong that we
talked about a little bit earlier is
being unduly dramatic we can call this
over apologizing
and the problem with this is that it
makes it more about the apologizer and
the attention that they get and the
framing that they get to have than the
actual apology
so if you're using really hyperbolic
language
you know i see this when people say oh i
can't imagine what you're going through
and i'm always like of course you can
imagine it you've got a faculty of
imagination you're a human being there's
almo there's by definition nothing
that's unimaginable for us
you can put your brain to it and do a
little bit of work and figure out how
the other person got hurt or how
humiliated they are or how insulted and
so to say
i can't understand that really places
the emphasis on me as the
apologizer and it takes it away from the
other person
you know saying i'm sorry from the
bottom of my heart uh you know that
could be useful but a lot of times it
seems almost so you know we use that
word performative this is performative
in a different sense right you're like
a performer on on the stage and you
gotta ask well who who are you doing
this for you're not doing it for the
person that you're apologizing to
so is it for yourself is it for the
camera is it for
the audience
because it's not reaching the person
you're apologizing for
yeah
and i guess this is a prime example of
when you see like those youtube
apologies
yeah i guess so i mean
tell me a little bit about those because
i haven't seen
as many as you have
ah i try not to watch them but
[Laughter]
uh you often see um someone being overly
performative they're they're um
a lot of times they're they're bawling
in order to like create a at least to
project that they're like sympathetic to
the point where they're they're falling
um you know it may be true that they are
but like it doesn't
it doesn't read as specifically you're
you're bawling because
you are sorry for the thing that you did
but
bawling because like everyone's like
uh telling you that you've done
something wrong
um
yeah for the most part is how that reads
as well as uh
you
will often like
um
have a lot of the things that we just
talked about of like you know not fully
apologizing for things and not taking
responsibility
it's the whole you know cornucopia of
different like bad apology
in in in these little nuggets of uh you
know youtube
history
yeah i mean so if we don't know the
person and we're seeing them on youtube
should should the default be that we
assume that their apologies are not
genuine
precisely because it's so easy to make a
fake apology and you know edit it and
sculpt it the way you want it to be
what do you think i i i don't want to go
to that i'm definitely into the you know
uh innocent until proven guilty okay um
and so i'll definitely go into it like
you know this could be i i don't want to
prejudge
okay
um do you want to talk about forgiveness
and the demands that people make that's
another way apologies go wrong
oh um
um
demanding forgiveness yeah um yeah so
this is one of the things we brought up
very beginning is that um at the end of
the apology um you can ask for
forgiveness to you know to restore that
relationship in some way
but
uh there's no
um
obligation for the person that was wrong
to actually give forgiveness um you know
this is
it's not like uh like an incantation or
a spell that you're just like i'm gonna
do this thing and then everything's just
right it it might take a lot of work
um and it might not ever work out for
you um and it you know you might have
done something that that revocably
breaks that relationship
and
you have to be aware of that when you're
doing this you have to be put into a a
vulnerable position otherwise this
doesn't really work
yeah
i mean um one of the things that was
talked about in that
article on corporate apologies
is and this is difficult i think for a
lot of leaders
is
the apology has to be empathetic
you actually have to like
you know connect with the the people
that you've wronged or harmed and see
that they are
ticked off they are scared they they
have all these other
feelings and those can get in the way of
them forgiving
maybe today maybe for you know a month
maybe forever
you know the other thing that we can say
too about bad apologies and then we'll
look at some some uh interesting
cases that come from the aita reddit
um if you screw up your apology
you've
you've done another bad action
and so
you've got something else to apologize
for when you've made a bad apology and i
think a lot of people
leave that out you know
if if your apology is insincere if you
don't follow up on it you've kind of
wasted everybody's time
you've
made it more about you than about the
restoration of the
relationship and and i i think a lot of
people
lose sight of that when they're engaging
in bad apologies you know
they don't realize that they're just
like heaping stuff on top of it so we've
got some interesting
aita uh
reddit forum things where people aita am
i the a-hole you know
people actually put these out and ask
other people hey what do you think about
this so
let me just read the first one and get
your take on this
um
it's
aita for not accepting my sister's
apology for her attitude on handouts now
that she's on the receiving end so it's
about some hypocrisy
i have two siblings and this involves
primarily my oldest sister growing up my
sister always had a boomer mentality
where we shouldn't get anything because
she never got it or how we should suffer
because she did she didn't like to see
us get any gifts or what she considered
handouts for free as she has a very
transactional mindset about these things
so if we get a gift now we owe the
gifter in some way my oldest sister has
always prided herself on being the
independent type one who doesn't take
handouts or sells herself based on
principle
now she's done a total 180 over the past
three years she went from being fully
independent on her own salary to jobless
and fully dependent on her husband my
mom's husband
me and my other sister
i kept quiet about how hypocritical
she's been for suddenly being okay with
gifts and becoming fully dependent on
others since people can change maybe
she's reflected on her situation but i
finally blew up at her after she got mad
at me for making a joke about how
different her 30th birthday present was
from our middle sister's 30th gift which
is a
thousand dollar paypal deposit from our
mom
i yelled about how poorly she treated us
growing up for the occasional gift and
how suddenly it's not a handout anymore
when she's the one on the receiving end
she
made a half-hearted apology about how
she treated us when we were younger and
when i told her she made me feel like a
horror for accepting money from my mom's
husband to pay for wisdom teeth surgery
when i was unemployed and had no
insurance she replied if it makes you
feel better that i can acknowledge
myself as a [ __ ] then i can do that i
am but does that make you feel better i
haven't accepted her apology and things
have been tense
she's been asking our other sister and
my husband why i'm still mad at her when
she hasn't done anything wrong when i
laid it out for her how bad she's been
and how hypocritical she is now that
she's finally benefiting
am i the a-hole
yes
sorry is she no i'm sorry she's not the
sister is yeah what do you think about
that one
um
the the big thing here um you know the
preamble is up to this apology right and
and she lays out the apol like the
things that she thought that her
sister had done that were not conducive
to a good relationship yeah and
specifically says
um you made me feel like a [ __ ]
and
that's a pretty that's a pretty strong
uh that's a very strong word
and instead of acknowledging
this and and taking responsibility that
she did this in fact she's like oh
well i guess i'm one too
and
that doesn't once again you with not
taking responsibility not acknowledging
the thing that
fully acknowledging the thing
um
and not like uh
offering any sort of restitution except
for like unless she thinks that you know
calling herself on
this word as well
makes her sister feel better but i don't
think so that i wouldn't call that
restitution yeah this is an interesting
one because i mean the broader thing is
there's a long-standing pattern of
behavior for years and years and years
making somebody feel bad for a specific
thing then doing that thing yourself
which is as she calls it out hypocrisy
right
and then um how do you how do you
address that you know i mean the best
way to address it would be to say i mean
you could say yes i am uh doing the same
thing
um i feel terrible about it um
clearly her sister doesn't feel bad
about it though right
so it was it it looks like a way in
which the sister could bully
the older sister could bully the younger
sisters and put them down
but she didn't really care about it
you know yeah
when push comes to shove
yeah so should she accept your apology i
say no you i think you do too right yeah
she she hasn't done the requirement and
and even if she did you know um
once again it it's not a requirement
that the the sister who were talking and
that's that's
writing this
um actually accept that yeah um i think
we have enough time to do one more is
there a particular case that you really
like
actually i wanted to talk about a
potential practice okay well let's do
that instead then okay
so um
here's an example of something what you
might try to do so we've already defined
kind of what
a uh a good and full uh apology should
be and so here's an example something
you might do
um recall one time that you apologized
poorly or failed to apologize and write
out that one apology of what that
apology should have been
kind of review that
um and
if you are feeling up to it
actually tell that person that apology
or apologize for the bad apology like
this is definitely caveats as i think
greg is going to come up but um at least
for
um
minor transgressions it seems to be
uh overall benefit
this is a really good one i think and
you know i i like the
going back into your your own mind and
seeking out the you know probably you
can find some time fairly recently when
you apologize badly i mean if you're me
you certainly can
[Laughter]
or failed to apologize at all and just
you know engage with the person but
didn't didn't apologize that could be
another thing
um
and yeah i mean do we have to have
caveats with this i mean don't
don't do it with somebody
who
you're
it wouldn't be a good idea to make
yourself vulnerable to like if somebody
was trying to scam you and you blew up
at them on the phone don't apologize to
them you know find somebody who's
more worthy of your apologies i would
say right
but this is but this is a good one
um
so for example like i you know
we we talked about earlier another uh
practice was like you know writing down
like at the end of the day what you did
well and what you you failed at and what
you could have done better and i found
you doing that at the end of the day
giving you a time to kind of reflect
gives me moments of like oh did i
actually treat this person well
and you know gives me the moment to you
know potentially go back to them and say
yeah i did this the other day it was
less than amazing i'm kind of sorry
about i'm no i'm not kind of i am sorry
about that i try not to do that again
i'm not gonna try to fall into my own
pitfalls here yeah um and i've done this
on with a number of people it definitely
um helped my relationship with my own
mom when i you know and sometimes curt
with her
yeah you know there's that expression
don't let the sun go down on an argument
never go to bed angry that that sort of
thing well if you're in a couple where
you've already done that
maybe the morning is the time to fix
that
so
yeah
um
so i think we should uh finish with our
final thoughts here correct yeah we're
pretty much out of time
all right so we leave you with the words
of
g k
chesterton
a stiff apology is a second insult the
injured party does not want to be
compensated because he has been wronged
he wants to be healed because he has
been hurt
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you